America's Special Operations Forces are
usually top secret but a new book sheds
light on some of their most daring
missions retired four-star Navy Admiral
William McRaven 'he's new book is called
sea stories my life in special
operations the Admiral is one of our
most decorated military leaders he
served as commander of all US special
operations forces and oversaw the Navy
SEAL raid that led to the death of
al-qaeda leader Osama bin Laden Admiral
McRaven also played a key role in the
capture of former Iraqi president Saddam
Hussein Admiral McRaven good morning
that's great thanks for being there to
have you here you didn't ever wear a
onesie did you it never wore off but I
am a big James Bond fan you could be the
next seal uniform I want to get to see
stories but before we do I want to get
to a story from the headlines today CBS
News has learned that President Trump
has apparently requested information
that could signal he's looking to pardon
soldiers accused of war crimes and in
some cases convicted of war crimes
including special operators and these
are some serious crimes being detailed
do you think that's an appropriate step
well certainly the president has the
authority to pardon whomever he can't do
it should he do can't do it so I mean I
think you have to look at each case case
by case and I don't know the specific
circumstances are the ones he's looking
at pardoning however one of the things I
think the president always has to be
cautious of is within the military we
have this thing called undue influence
so if there is an ongoing investigation
as a senior officer you're not
authorized you're not allowed to imply
how you think the outcome of that that
case ought to be that's called unduly
influencing the man or woman in charge
of that that investigation so the
president has to be careful about
signaling his intent again once the
investigation is complete if the
president reads about it and he decides
that that individual needs to be
pardoned well within his authority the
cases that had not even gone to trial
yet so again I think the president just
needs to be cautious about signaling
what he thinks the appropriate outcome
of those investigations should be though
generally speaking do you think it's a
good idea after they've already been
convicted I know he has Authority he can
do whatever he wants but generally
speaking do you think it's a good idea
well again I'd be a little reluctant to
talk about it
oddly I think I'd have to look at each
individual case president Trump tweeted
yesterday if Iran wants to fight that
will be the official end of Iran are you
concerned we could be headed to a major
conference yes I'm not as concerned as I
think a lot of people are the president
doesn't want to go to war in Iran the
Iranians certainly don't want to go to
war with us
I haven't seen the intelligence that is
kind of kind of predicating all of this
but the fact the matter is if there are
threats out there we know how to deal
with those threats we know how to
elevate our security status and trust me
the United States Navy has been dealing
with the Iranians in the Persian Gulf
for 4050 years they will take care of
the fleet and they didn't the Iranians
do not want to engage us in the Persian
Gulf that will not end well for them do
you mind if we turn to see stories no
ma'am I want to talk about the Osama bin
Laden chapter because it for me it was
one of the most detailed things I've
ever read about what happened with Osama
bin Laden you were part of the team who
briefed the president you certainly saw
the seals right before they went on that
mission and what did you want us to know
because it was you took us on a step by
step very harrowing story what's your
big takeaway for us in that yeah you
know I offer the takeaway is while you
know the seals and the night stalkers
the helicopter pilots that participated
in the raid we were honored and
fortunate enough to be the kind of the
final piece of this this very
challenging puzzle at the end of the day
it was about the hundreds of thousands
of soldiers sailors airmen Marines
civilians the CIA the NSA everybody that
contributed to bringing bin Laden to
justice I know that Admiral but at the
end of the day you're there as the seals
are getting their headsets on they're
playing music they're getting ready to
go in and do this and there were two
occasions on that night where you say
you choked up yourself yes Oshin well
again it's hard not to get emotional
when you know you've spent your you know
most of your adult life trying to bring
justice after 9/11 so you know certainly
when the when the guys got back across
the border and I knew they were safe and
I for all intent and purpose the mission
was over yeah this there's a certain
emotional relief that happens as a
result of were you at all nervous that
night you know I wasn't all that nervous
I had kind of hand selected the
commander's I knew what the capability
of the guys were I knew that we could do
this mission yeah an obviously we didn't
know where the bin Laden was there and
and I go back to the decision that
President Obama made an incredibly
courageous decision to go in when
frankly it was about a 50/50 chance that
he was there yeah and and the work that
the CIA did and Leon Panetta and I think
that will go down as one of the the
great intelligence operations in the
history of American intelligence rigor
and courage involved I do want to get to
one thing there's a generation following
yours the millennial generation not
known for rigor and courage overall but
you say in fact you think they will be
the greatest generation of the 21st
century I do tell me why well I think it
would be surprised I am probably the
biggest fan of the Millennials you'll
ever meet and you know I always Sharon
let's maligned the much maligned
Millennials yeah and I you know they
talk about the Millennials being soft
and pampered and entitled well I'm quick
to say then you've never seen seen them
in a firefight in Afghanistan or I was
the Chancellor of the University of
Texas System I watched these young men
and women working their way through
college to make a better life for them
and their families let me tell you this
is a fabulous generation and anybody
that worries about the future of the
United States I don't think you need to
worry we're gonna be in good hands I
love what you said about that too but I
also love how you talk about the love
for your wife George Ann who's here
today and I know we have to go but
that's a great stuff and the fact you're
a hugger I'm a hugger now I'm okay with
that we are too McRaven thanks so much
for being here the book is C stories my
life in Special Operations it goes on
sale tomorrow